welcome
to this video playing Raphael bakoons
yeah I played this guy only recently
remember don't remember what exactly
this game was
yeah a red team and he accepts this Pawn
sacrifice
okay
maybe Knight A3 is more precise I keep
forgetting the precise move or is him
IR Queen D5 hmm
oh
this Nike one
it's been a while since I'm
studied this in detail
then
there are lots of lines here where white
is um giving up this pawn and I tend to
confuse them it's just like that
okay
white um very often is sacrificing a
pawn like it happens here
and um it's all
similar but not quite the same and I
keep confusing the lines
if he takes now Knight takes I will get
an additional Tempo on the queen with
Bishop E3
and in general this is a very nice
compensation the bishop on G2 is very
strong
he's not taking yet
not sure why
it really if we go back before this
pre-move is entered
um yeah I don't know yeah you can do
that but
is it really um helping him much I can
can get this Tempo anyway
Bishop D4 is not making much sense I can
take here
um yeah this is this is just an
interesting
position where you have um ample
compensation it's a question however
what the most precise way to play is
um
Knight C4
it's one possibility
also taking it's not uh totally off
Nazi form
yeah Knight C4 will probably take
there's also B4 B5
as a possibility
if he goes E6
in the near future it um
and this is this is somewhat hurting the
Dynamics of the position
okay and try to
get get the Knight into play
yeah this is this is the the most um
ambitious way to play
for black
k95
oh probably Queen C7
okay I'm going for this pressure on B7
takes I'm going to take with the pawn
and I intend to play
Knight A5 is what I wanted to do
right but I need a rook here
then Knight A5
yeah it's very solid for black Maybe
maybe this uh wasn't that great in the
first place for a while
Knight A5 yeah okay you cannot play b6s
Knight E5 is hitting him
so
the big issue is that this Knight on D5
is a fantastic piece
it really blocks the whole position
so this is
this is very problematic but yeah Knight
A5 is is an annoying move
um and there are some some nice points
let's say queen C7 maybe I can can even
play
um
night if A5 even then
yeah well Rook B8 Bishop A7 is not good
or Rook B8 Knight C6 so yeah this is
what I expected he has to return return
material
um yeah okay not not I need to take this
otherwise the whole thing does not make
any sense
and now of course he will play Rook B8
but I have Knight A5 Knight C6 so I'll
get
some stuff back is there anything else
no probably not
so just take here probably
threatens Knight E7 also
no 97 is quite an annoyance
um so taking on A7 I guess
yeah let's let's grab this
it will take them
no hmm maybe him
yeah I still have the the weak Pawn on
D3
but I also have um rather active pieces
here
okay
yeah I guess Knight E5 yes
maybe intending also Rook to C8
setting up this annoying
situation on the back rank
so I'm going to refresh this idea
no black is under some some pressure
um
yeah I can still do that
so maybe here
and what's now
is there any way to do this maybe Rook
B1 B7
Rook B7 he can move the Knight
by the way exactly to be form
Maybe
I would like to remove the Bishop from
the attack
it would be uh rather nice
is there any way to do that on Knight C6
is not helping
time warning before
it's not that's not easy at all really
I don't see a great way forward him
to be honest it looks nice but
how am I making any progress
we treat this voluntarily but on A1
I can still go night before this is not
um this is not helping me at all I guess
oh I didn't see that coming at all
stupid
ah what am I doing here oh my God
ah wow
yeah well this is a great idea we're
trying to get something I was totally
losing the threat and spending ages
oh no yeah this happens when you play
very early in the morning
oh shouldn't do that
yeah around here I wanted to to to try
to do I mean white is better but I did I
didn't really know how to do it
well this is the normal move but the
night before irritated me
now of course I can just go here I
didn't see that at all
and get here white is just better of
course
if I can win this an entirely different
matter but um
very very soon I really couldn't
couldn't see a Way Forward here
this this was uh stupid to begin with
but okay I still shouldn't lose of
course but I I I totally I totally uh I
totally plundered the C6 Knight
uh oh wow
yeah I mean I can I can just take and
and do this whatever and I'm not losing
this ever but I simply blunt at the
piece ah yeah really
shouldn't play when you're not awake
stupid stupid stupid
yeah it was actually quite nice and with
this activity
but um yeah I'm still difficult rupee
seven yeah rupees seven
what I didn't really appreciate is that
I can go to E3 other other squares are
not as good I mean something like this
um it's it's not that great in
comparison he attacks stuff him
so yeah even that is okay but
yeah so I just simply should play the
move why why am I not doing that
not making things far too complicated
Bishop A1 is after night before it's
really a stupid move
in terms of playing for an advantage
yeah okay thanks for watching